before I call the Prime Minister may I
say how pleased I am to see him in the
house
I hope
[Applause]
I hope we will see more
made in the house first going forward
I'm sure we can work together on that I
know call the prime minister to make his
statement
thank you Mr Speaker I have just
returned from the NATO Summit in Vilnius
where we strengthen the NATO alliance
and confirmed Britain place at its heart
faced with a more volatile and dangerous
World a mechanized war in Europe and
increasing aggression from authoritarian
States
we must show those who would challenge
our security and prosperity that NATO is
United